[Music]
hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events from the love
people use things tour if you'd like to
see us on the road visit
theminimalists.com
tour or you can find all of our live
events over at patreon.com slash the
minimalists
while i've got you here i'd love to talk
to you about shame as well because i
think quite often in the new book we
talk a lot about some of the things that
we've been
ashamed to admit until recently and
we've had to come to terms with it but
shame
not only does it do we carry it with us
but it often compels some pretty
dumb behaviors in our lives
ways that we try to sort of circumvent
the shame
hide the shame
deny
the shame
deny past events deny the present
do other things that we're going to be
ashamed of in order to hide the shame
so can we talk a bit about
about shame and and and where it comes
from and
and how do we better understand it
well you can't talk about shame i
thought this is
the home of
dr brown right and so i mean it's
everything i would say would be in
service to anything for her mark bernay
brown he's a professor at uh um
the way i explain shame is
let's say i violate one of my core
values i violate a value
and suddenly from the sky drops a brick
and i've got to hold it
that's guilt
i screwed up
i texted that guy
and i'm married to somebody else i
yelled at my kid i fudged numbers at
work a little bit like it like it
violated a core value
that's guilt and i think that's good i
think it's appropriate we need to have
that accountability with our own values
shame is when i take that brick and i
put it in my backpack and i say this is
who i am
not
i screwed up here i lied it is i'm a
liar and i'm gonna wear that and if you
study trauma over time you learn that
trauma is both acute it happens at one
time but it's also cumulative it adds up
on you right so it can be a bunch of
little pebbles that add up over time
that you keep putting your backpack
keeping your backpack and it's benign
some of it's little like when you're 11
years old and you walk down the stairs
and your mom looks at you and says oh
honey
um
that shirt makes you look pudgy and you
want to you want the boys to like you
right and boys don't like budgie girls
you want to be a pretty girl right and
you're 11 and you're like yeah or dad
says
you know but
we don't we don't strike out in this
family you hit the ball you don't stand
up at the stupid plate and put that bat
on your shoulder we swing the bat in
this family that's what the kind of guys
we are right and so you're like yes sir
yes sir yes sir i just wanna i just i
wanna be loved i wanna be loved i wanna
be loved and i'm putting those in there
and over time
you become 35 and 40 and that backpack
is just so heavy unbearable that's shame
and i don't want anyone to know what's
in that
and earlier what you said about
relationships all we ever want to know
is
do you really know me
really
and
do you still love me all right
so in this room i've got some buddies
who have been with me mike and tom and
tom
since i was a child i was like 12 maybe
they know me they know me when i used to
be like a crazy liar i was nuts i was in
i was not i was insane right
and we've had kids together we've
grieved together we've had gone to
weddings together
um
those people know me and they still love
me right and that is
my whole body just saying that it i just
do that i turn into this guy i'm just
like chilling right it everything works
out good right so it's
that's that is how i describe shame and
if i can let people into my backpack and
let them see what's in there
then we are free
right if i can take those bricks out and
set them down and say i'm not carrying
that anymore that's beautiful that's
free did you enjoy this video if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free